con profunda preocupación Estados Unidos
Reino Unido y tres países europeos
Alemania Francia e Italia han subrayado
que se oponen a la decisión de Israel de
regularizar nuevas asentamientos
ilegales en cisjordania y construir casi
10.000 viviendas en asentamientos ya
existentes en un comunicado conjunto
estas naciones advierten que esta
expansión solo servirá para aumentar las
tensiones entre israelíes y palestinos y
alejar una solución de dos estados
palabras que siguen la línea de las ya
pronunciadas previamente por la Unión
Europea la liga árabe y el secretario
general de la ONU como lo reitero
Antonio Gutiérrez todos los
asentamientos en territorio palestino
ocupado son ilegales bajo la ley
internacional Pero además estos nueve
que fueron construidos sin ningún
permiso también son ilegales bajo la ley
israelí de hecho la regularización de
estas colonias judías choca con varios
aspectos muchas erigieron en tierras
privadas palestinas e incluso Hay una
que se ubica en lo que el ejército
israelí considera una zona de tiro un
argumento que Israel usa para demoler
algunas comunidades palestinas además la
regularización se topa con el tribunal
supremo que podría oponerse a esta
decisión un poder de veto que perdería
si se llega a aplicar la reforma
judicial del gobierno de netanyahu de
ahí que los colonos la apoyen tanto aún
así El Ejecutivo de netanyahu justifica
estas acciones como una respuesta al
atropello del 10 de febrero en el que
murieron tres israelíes dos de ellos
menores y el propio ministro de
seguridad y tamar no solo desestimó el
rechazo internacional sino que declaró
que nuevas asentamientos No son
suficientes y quiere legalizar muchos
más